this is Natalie McNally she was 32 years
old and pregnant with her first child
when stabbed to death in her home just
before Christmas
he said God hey we are going to
face these days without I know all our
presents were hard for all wrapped up
we're all upstairs and you look at them
and heartbreaking
three weeks on her parents Noel and
Bernie say it's possible her killer
could have fled Northern Ireland and
they won't rest until he's apprehended
our baby life
I don't have to thank God in our last
few minutes was she pleading for her
life was she pleading for her baby's
life you don't that's all comes into
your head our last few what was our last
few minutes like you know we think for
the weekends and this and women in this
community living on their own like they
must be terrified you know that there's
a monster still out on the streets you
know and I I I feel for them to tell you
the truth you know
police have released these CCTV pictures
of the suspect on the night of Natalie's
murder and believe they've recovered the
weapon used in the attack
do you think given the nature of her
death that there is someone out there
beyond the killer who knows I think yeah
there's bound to be somebody's prone to
know the Killer and if you kill somebody
that way you can't just like go home and
act normally and we could just you know
feather their heart you know to
give up loyalty and just go straight to
the place you know you can't be loyal to
somebody that don't understand
but he could do it to someone else and
you wouldn't want that
Northern Ireland has the joint highest
female homicide rate in Europe storm and
fell silent when first Minister
designate Michelle O'Neill hosted a
vigil for Natalie
you know I just just loved her just
loved her the day she was born and
she was a very good
it's so much part of our lives and this
is not like that's what really that's
just
well it's just I can't remember I can't
think tea of a future I can't say
there'll be no joy in life never ever
gone
she's gone
they've lost their daughter and all they
have left is the hope of Justice
David Blevins Sky News in craigavon